we will stay with the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller from
the eight one three area code eight one
three who's this and what's on your mind
today this is Glenn in Tampa Florida hey
David I was just wondering I'm not
trying to be conspiratorial or anything
like that okay but when people talked
about with did the Vegas shooting the
other night and everything and they said
they heard shots on the ground and I was
just wondering it's not being
conspiratorial I don't think there was
like this multiple planned terrorist
attack like that yeah our false flag
that's ridiculous
but don't you think it's possible since
I believe Nevada is open carry people
and there were a lot of people there
yeah and don't you think it's it's not
inconceivable that somebody they hear
the gunshots they're they're packing I
mean they freak out and they start
shooting in the general direction of
where the shots are coming from and do
you think that's possible where people
were hearing the shots on the ground it
was people like that who are trying to
be proactive better me your rose okay
very good so I like the question because
you're being you're you're proposing
something that's an alternative to the
official story but you're doing it in a
in a more critically thinking way you're
not just being hyperbolic and
conspiratorial I think that the phrasing
you're using which is is it conceivable
that being Nevada that someone else did
take out a gun and maybe fired that gun
I think it is absolutely conceivable I
think it is also absolutely conceivable
that people who were on the ground
thought that they were hearing what
sounded like firearms being fired from
the ground but it was actually echo
ricocheting and absolute and total chaos
that made people believe that maybe that
was going on when really it wasn't and I
think that that I mean when we when you
see the video the eyewitness video that
was taken of what was going on there and
and when you research this idea of being
able to identify the direction of
gunfire and and sort of the difficulties
implicit with that I think that that is
probably even more likely you know yeah
yeah I was just wondering the again like
I said because I thought maybe there was
just possibly some validity to it yeah
and given that again I've heard people
say the reason I brought up was after
the theater shooting in Aurora
there were people calling who were
I'm very Chozen up whatnot we're saying
you know if I had had a gun if I'd have
been in a theater yeah I would have
taken a guy out and response you know
was you to kill more people so I was
just wondering maybe did that that was
my theory that maybe somebody was trying
to be hero and just start shooting in
the general direction and that might
have been what people were hearing it
wasn't the vaguest scenario really
illuminates the idea of the good guy
with the gun is the solution to the
problem in the Aurora Colorado theater
shooting you're talking about more
people shooting at firearms in a dark
room is going to solve the problem and
in Vegas imagine that three or four
people do take out guns police show up
they hear gunshots and see armed people
even if they're good guys with guns
those people are probably getting shot
right so it would not have been of much
use in that particular case so Glenn
thank you appreciate it always there
from Tampa Florida